hi I'm Jodi Whittaker and this is Doctor
Who support there we go
Bryn Hajin has asked if I was able to
ask the doctor or you can a question it
would be how do you manage to balance a
home / Timelord lifestyle and I would
say it creates chaos and havoc and epic
adventure but that is all the things you
want from life that answers your
question brim Joff has asked you have a
TARDIS and know how to pilot it where
when would you go okay I think I would
go to Neptune in 50 years just to see if
our lessons have been learned if we have
perspective from Neptune and we can look
back on this beautiful universe have we
made the right choices for all those
other planets
it's Neptune because in our solar system
is the farthest away if we're not
counting Pluto so I think it would give
an excellent sense of perspective that's
why I would do also Neptune's dark and
stormy and quite like quite a bit of
atmosphere Ryan Smith has asked is the
doctor ever going to oil her squeaky
hinge on the TARDIS door I've got so
many important things to be doing every
day like saving the universe I've got to
leave that to somebody else Heather Roca
has asked odd thought for the day does
the doctor ever wash their clothes you
always see them in the same outfit right
is there a day where they just stay in
the TARDIS in some PJ's and wait for
their clothes to be washed no I just
don't think particular my doctor I don't
think I have the patience for that I
think I've developed such an
extraordinary outfit that is
self-cleaning Michael Hardy what the
hell in capital letters has happened to
Gallifrey do you think I'm gonna spoil
that now I am NOT
Liss at covered in bees 67 has asked has
the 13th doctor used any aliases Doctor
Who I want to know what she will call
herself when she can't say that she's
the doctor so well I've got an excellent
gadget called a psychic paper and when I
want to be a little bit sneaky of a
completely different alias just flash my
psychic paper and nine times out of ten
it gives a wonderful description of what
I think would be an appropriate way for
me to sneak into a building if I don't
want to reveal that I am The Time Lord
with two hearts Oh Sean Scott Smith
doctor who was fantastic last night
thank you has anyone ever sprouted a fan
theory that the doctor and the master of
the same being like a split personality
I'd believe it I've never heard that
that might be one of those things that's
a very big conversation online that I've
missed I believe wholeheartedly that we
are not the same person I think you can
disagree but I would say I would say not
Highbury
your question is anyone else want to
give the doctor a hook no just me well
you can because I love a hug I'm very
tactile this is from who fan site where
do you think the 13th doctor got those
goggles from they were in the woman who
fell to earth and now they're in the new
series just curious what do you think
well they were found by our
extraordinary costume designer Rhea
Holman and they were loved so much by
Jamie child's the director of the woman
who fell to earth and they got such a
fantastic response I think we just like
we brought them back again but what I
like to think of them as is my nod to
Doc Brown and if you don't know who that
is
Back to the Future giant think holophone
hashtag Jodie Whittaker is becoming
another great hashtag Doctor Who but
it's always going to bother me that she
was able to build a new sonic
screwdriver
how did she build the software she
couldn't do that she could I know she we
are so clever sometimes I was able to
because I was able to steal
thing from Tim Shaw and that helped me
along the way I was also in Sheffield
and they have excellent steel those were
all the things that I needed and a
little bit of who belief in myself that
got me that brand new sonic that works
perfectly Amy now she has asked why is
the doctor being so secretive about
where she is from now I would say it's a
Pandora's box to ask the doctor where
they're from and I think particularly
knowing how curious Rania's and grandma
do wouldn't accept necessarily the one
or two-word answer that I would be
willing to give without revealing so
much of my past which some of it is a
joyous memory some of it is incredibly
sad some of it is steeped in loss and I
think that conversation is often too big
in the moments that they have together
Essie is asked does the doctor have a
bedroom in the TARDIS I'd say yeah I
don't think it will be frequented very
often because as I've said before I'm
incredibly hyperactive and I think the
just the brain never sleeps but I would
say they do in in this season we've
discovered that there's a wardrobe hole
and karaoke buses so I think missing out
a bedroom would be a huge error so Santa
may jamario SMM VA has asked I've always
wondered if the doctor was able to get a
cleaner for the TARDIS what would the
bill be for the inside I mean if you've
seen episode three of this season
there's a giant tentacle that we're
mopping up so I'd say pretty hefty I
mean there's custard cream crumbs on the
floor there's muddy footprints I don't
have lots of time to do cleaning I'm not
a complete scruff but I'd say it
probably put quite a hefty bill Mahr
Kashyyyk
how can the sonic screwdriver work on a
rope when it can't even work on
something as basic as would cut you I
read about my sonic my Sonic's brilliant
I'm not even gonna comment on it is
absolutely flawless in my opinion
Howard Nelson is asked how many lies
does a gala for him cap have I will
never sleep again
mm-hmm Gallifreyan cat
I mean infinite let's give it up to
really blow your mind
have yourself a cookie little Christmas
john-boy cook has asked so genuine
question for all who viens how long have
you been a fan when you realize that the
rhythm of the theme tune is a Time Lord
double heartbeat well I say it was
revealed to me so I'm not embarrassed to
say lots of things to reveal to me
that's why I love playing the part
because every day is a learning day but
yeah I thought that was a beautiful
addition to the episode and it was a
reveal to me if I'm now gonna get
hounded because I should have known that
I apologize profusely Beth the name
she's asked I'm thinking of getting this
tattoo on my wrist yes my first tattoo
what's everyone's opinion I don't have
any tattoos
I'd go on about it all the time I've got
an idea for one and I was still at 37
have not got it I would think very
carefully okay heads I do because what
if you taste changes but as designs go
is absolutely beautiful so I'm not
discouraging the artists artistic work
on your wrist at all cuz it's beautiful
but I would say how do you know you're
gonna like it in 40 years I'm always
curious about that with people with
tattoos I wish I have long that kind of
longevity in my taste
I'm impressed if you do biggest digests
at BBC can we please c13 meet the face
of BOE hashtag Doctor Who hashtag 13th
Doctor
hashtag face of BOE we cannot reveal
anything that is going to happen ever
because why be a fan of Doctor Who if
you were going to have spoilers so I'm
not answering so type 40 marketing if
nothing can get into the TARDIS how did
the KaBlam delivery bot manager well
let's use an analogy like a vampire
there was a signal and I accepted the
signal because I've been waiting for a
delivery so it's a bit like it was
invited in and because of that the
hologram esque delivery BOTS arrived and
brought me my beautiful beautiful
beautiful present the Renaissance of bad
ideas so Mary Poppins is a Thai blood
right Oh
Oh hmm so I'm not the first female I
just pulled the rug out of it there we
go
Lauren is asked oh she hasn't asked
should put in quotes I love a laminator
why is 13 the most relatable
I do love a laminator actually although
in this day and age I don't know how
good a laminator is it's not ideal for
recycling but it does keep things very
clean and if you're putting on your wall
you don't need to put a nail in you
could just put blue tack so it's always
really handy because if you take the
taste change as I've just discovered
that my taste change quite regularly
because I won't be getting a tattoo soon
um you can just peel off on the night
off the floor from blue tack you don't
have blue tack the yeah JetBlue tack all
right cool there you go that's your
answer
Ryan Kennedy is asked how does the
TARDIS always land on flat ground it
always sounds on flat ground because I'm
an excellent pilot also because we have
a brilliant art department who found a
really wonderful location every time
they have to build it and they're just
helping us out it's a lot of people to
get in there if it's wanted with tipple
over especially if we get Brad in there
we're all tipped over
silent rumbles how did the doctor
survive the fall from atmosphere to the
Train
I'd say I'd taken a huge intake of
breath I then have really good lung
capacity to scream throughout the entire
fall so that my first then second my
next intake of breath was done so
smoothly on the train floor that when I
bobbed up into frame that change of
atmosphere had no effect on me
artistic license poppy
since when can the doctor drive a car
she can barely drive the TARDIS she's
getting better and I had a few how shall
I say that it's in my first three
episodes I did attempt to land in
Sheffield in the 21st century and it
went a little bit wrong but thank
goodness for those little errors because
we ended up in some phenomenal
adventures and witnessing some
extraordinary moments in history so you
know it was it was a new interior I had
to learn how to drive it but now I'd say
I'm pretty pretty flawless I'm also a
really good driver and
we're very hard for me Jodie Whittaker
is the actor to kind of fudge my
extraordinary driving into bad driving
on set
well I'm Jodie where to get a nice it
for Doctor Who support I will see you in
the next 900 years